social media is playing a major role in
the rescue efforts Twitter and Facebook
pages are filled not only with posts
requesting help but offering help as
well people connected to a Galveston
County nursing home say the emergence of
this image online this unforgettable
image helps speed up the arrival of help
Omar Villafranca is in Houston this
morning Omar good morning this may be
the most tweeted about natural disaster
in history if anything because there's
more people on social media now than
there were 12 years ago during Hurricane
Katrina and people are coming out and
they're posting about things in their
neighborhood like water levels like this
one here or asking for help but it's
still not clear whether all the postings
are hurting or helping rescue efforts
this is what it looked like inside the
la vita bella' nursing home in dickinson
texas about 30 miles southeast of
downtown Houston Ruth Miller was one of
the 15 elderly residents stranded suzhen
Beaubourg is her sister it already
called 911 the TV was saying don't call
9-1-1 anymore and nobody is coming to
rescue them the woman who owns the
nursing home took this photo her
son-in-law posted it on Twitter with the
caption need help ASAP emergency
services please retweet it was retweeted
hundreds of times we spoke with him on
the phone from his Florida home I don't
have a large Twitter following I do a
whole lot of tweeting but I was like
well let's put it on Twitter and see if
we can get some action from it about
three hours after they tweeted the photo
all 15 senior citizens were rescued our
cameras were rolling as three women we
believe were part of that group were
lifted onto a rescue vehicle my thanks
are definitely out too not just the
authorities but also to all the Twitter
followers and actually believe the story
and retweeted it and got everything in
motion an official we spoke with says
rescuers were already on the way when
the photo started getting attention
online it was just one of many social
media posts calling attention to people
needing rescues including a Facebook
group with over 80,000 followers formed
during the storm
but agencies including
FEMA the US Coast Guard and the Houston
Police Department asked people not to
use social media for rescue requests
Houston Police said 900 is the best way
to capture your request and make sure it
is properly dispatched social media has
been helpful in one way Galveston County
put out a call for help and a Cajun Navy
that you've been hearing about while
they are in the Houston area and they
are already out helping to rescue people
Omar thank you